what have people been asking you about
so far but being human just saying is it
coming back please say it's coming back
and yeah good support actually a lot of
people really do like being human didn't
they
yeah just asking with hits if he's
coming back I think that's the main one
and the answer is yes yes it is what you
enjoyed so far about being in the show
everything it's my favorite my favorite
show favorite favorite part I love doing
it
it gives me an opportunity to do some
actual good acting you're not I mean a
good character I could just get the
teeth into and give it some rather than
be a character that's quite close to me
so there's Tom's no dark meter so it
gives me an opportunity to have a good
go at somewhere nothing like yourself
I've seen a film that even in recently
called 28k it's coming out in October
isn't it premiered at least and Film
Festival and in that you're doing an
accent which is completely not your own
isn't it it's the first time as well
yeah I'm scared to death like watching
it it was I watched it only the other
day laughter but today that festival
yeah quite relieved actually I thought
was a good good little film but horrible
horrible sod - I am in it I'm scary to
watch what attracted you to the park in
28k oh I'll just play a bad Monday no I
just want it's a very little bit of a
gang stuff
normally I play like like chavvy rude
boys you know what I mean but this one
had a bit wearing nice clothes had a bit
of a swagger on him I'm sort of I
thought it'd be a nice little different
gangster part to play anyway how did you
find doing the accent because you go
southern in this don't you I hate it I
hate up unless I know the accent really
well I get a bit worried about it you
know what I mean but it was all right
I'm gonna do a lot more accent training
the things I'm gonna do jobs all over
the world get meself glued or that's the
one yeah get me to America America would
you like to be doing that Xbox from
obviously the next series of being human
I want to do some stage work I ain't
done any stage work since I was 19 and
I think I was a bit scared a couple
years ago I went to a bit of a dick
where I thought I'm too scared on stage
but I think now is the time I want to go
out there and do a bit of stage and if
we first professional play when I was 19
and then and them a place since I want
to I wanna do some more on you if you
pick up any play what would it be
I'd want to do a new play when I've
never seen before so I can make my own
interpretation is no other influence I'm
gonna do my own so they can say that you
began the raw idiot and then when they
made the film and when I go Michael
socrata better in the stage excellent
but look forward to seeing you on the
stage always finding out more about the
new so there being human and watching it
and thanks the thing - thank you very
much cheers for that
you